[Music]
irregularities
abound in the 2020 presidential election
which we still don't have an answer to
irregularities by the way is a very soft
word for fraud
that's that's the that's the polite word
that we all use but we're looking
at a lot of problems in the election be
it in pennsylvania
uh in georgia and michigan lots of
questions not a lot of answers
working its way through the court system
we are joined now
by a man who predicted that this would
happen who called that there would be
these issues of fraud throughout the
election more so even
than usual that would be the great
dinesh d'souza author of approximately
seven zillion books filmmaker
extraordinaire
and most recently the filmmaker behind
trumpcard
you know we spoke to dinesh a few weeks
ago when the movie came out i hope
you've seen it
since then but if not we will give you
another opportunity and we will discuss
what's going to happen in this election
dinesh thanks so much for coming on
my pleasure dinesh i
i also i i agreed with you and with your
take
that this election was going to have a
lot of problems with it i figured this
would go on for a long time it would
work its way
through the courts but there's something
very frustrating because
conservatives are very good at
predicting the fraud
but we're not great at identifying it in
the moment proving it overturning it
flipping it around
what do you think the trump team and
conservatives generally have to do right
now
to try to salvage this election
well i think the most important thing is
to produce
in a kind of comprehensive way the
evidence of
systematic fraud not just episodic fraud
a case here a case there
but rather is fraud that is built into
the way the election was organized um
you show this through a combination of
statistical techniques
through i mean if you can produce
machines that have the capacity to
trade votes uh if you have
whistleblowers that can come forward
this is the kind of bomb
evidence needed so it has to be
presented in a public manner
and also in a legal manner and it has to
be done simultaneously so this is really
what we're waiting for and the clock is
ticking on it
but i have confidence in sydney powell
and the team to be able to make this
case we're just all eagerly waiting to
see it
and for those who don't know who is
sydney powell cindy powell
came to a popularity as mike flynn's
attorney
and as sort of exposed a lot of
corruption
but what is sydney's role in all of this
well sydney powell picked up the michael
flynn case
and um was able to uh peel off some
members of the onion that showed that
both hillary clinton and obama were the
ringleaders of this operation in other
words just as we thought
you know it's implausible that comey and
clapper and strzok and paige and brennan
all these guys
they didn't go off on independent
surveillance expeditions
somebody gave the order uh
somebody looks to have been barack obama
so this is a very powerful
um set of facts that has come out and
the judge of course in the flynn case
has been doing his best to sort of
throw water on the fire and try to put
it out or at least postpone it kick the
can
down the road so sidney powell has
become kind of a legend in the legal
community
and is not known for making reckless
irresponsible statements i think for
this reason
there's a great deal of anxiety but also
anticipation
in what she's about to unfurl well this
is the issue because what you're hearing
from democrats and what you're hearing
from
some of these weak need conservatives
you know the ones who
congratulated joe biden before the
election was over and you know really
want president trump to concede
where you're hearing is these are
reckless irresponsible allegations we
have no real evidence of fraud you got
to put up or shut up
come on no big deal here and it strikes
me that
the issue with voter fraud especially
when you've got widespread unsolicited
mail-in ballots is
it's extraordinarily difficult to
identify the isolated cases as you say
don't necessarily show systemic fraud so
what are the
what do we say to these people who tell
us ah sorry you don't have enough
evidence
well the first thing is that republicans
have this kind of
default position of going nambi pamby
when the going gets tough and it's
important to realize that this is what
feeds the aggression of the left the
confidence of the left in doing these
shenanigans
is based upon the idea that they can
count on us to do nothing about it
and i think this is happens across the
board their view is look we can knock
down your monuments
because you won't knock down our
monuments we can unleash the deep state
against you
because we know that you'll never
unleash the deep state against us right
we can pack the court
because we know that even if you had all
the power you'd never pack the court and
weaken rig elections
knowing that not only would you not
dream of doing it but you're likely to
go along with it and certify
the results of a rigged election so they
count on us to be suckers and sure
enough one or two of us are
but i think on the balance the
republican base is not giving in on this
and this is what is unnerving the left
for the first time
a trump has sort of installed a little
backbone in our side
and we're holding firm as we should i'm
so pleased to see it i remember in 2016
when president trump
was nominated or when he was about to be
nominated you had all of these
republicans say oh no
he isn't really conservative and then
you look at his record and you realize
he's much more conservative in practice
than any of those people ever were but
what really seems to irk them
is this backbone is this courage i mean
we're being told right now
that if and we're being told this by
basically the entire establishment media
including outlets that we thought were
on our side maybe they're not so much on
our side
we're being told that if president trump
does not concede this election before
the legal process
plays out that we're somehow
overthrowing democratic norms
it's a threat to democracy what do we
say to that
well let's look at the orwellian um
society that the left has not only been
trying to impose but they've gotten
pretty far
down the road um the signature elements
of orwellianism if you want to call that
or orwell country are number one the
rewriting of history
check number two newspeak the uniformity
of the media i mean think about
what it means when we say that the media
in general did not cover the biggest
story of the election think of how hard
it is to pull that off
there are thousands of reporters there
are hundreds of media organizations
was there not one enterprising guy at
the dallas morning news of the
sacramento bee who goes listen
my idiot colleagues don't want to cover
the biggest story of the election thank
you i will step forward but even that
guy was scared to do it
even he knew that he would wouldn't work
in journalism anymore so
the degree of uniform and then finally
the social intimidation antifa digital
censorship
so these guys who have been not only
violating the spirit of democracy
but the guardrails of our society
they're running roughshod over the bill
of rights they want to lecture us about
the democratic process
i don't think we should pay any
attention to these clowns i think you're
totally right it reminds me of when
the left scolds conservatives on racial
issues
on racism and i think how dare you the
left
has the worst record on race in this
country that i can imagine
in particular and you've worked on this
quite a bit the democratic party as
as absolutely the worst record on race
in this country how dare you lecture me
i don't i don't care what you have to
say about that
and of course it's the same thing when
it comes to democratic norms when it
comes to
the constitution but one worry i have
even beyond all the policy great policy
will lose the great leadership will lose
if president trump does not manage to
eke out this election
is we won't be able to uncover the
corruption
you know in in many ways trump wasn't
supposed to win in 2016
the reason we've figured out all the
shenanigans that happened during the
obama administration is impo
is in part because trump did win do you
think there is
any hope if you know worst case scenario
biden is named president
is there any way for conservatives to go
in there and expose what they've done or
will that be just lost to history
well the investigative resources on our
side are quite limited and this is our
own fault
the truth of the matter is you know if i
were running fox news
i would have hired a hundred
investigative reporters to dig
behind lift all the stones and look
underneath
i wouldn't have set up something that
could be just called talk radio on tv
because that's ultimately nothing more
than punditry
you know it seems to me it occurs to me
this is
my opinion that's important but it's not
as important
as facts because people are facts are
what really change minds
i what what i worry about is let's say
we have
irrefutable evidence of systematic fraud
and nothing happens
let's say the courts go it's not our
jurisdiction or it's too late it's over
or
get used to it this will actually put us
in a very awkward position because we
will feel then
we will be a captive population inside
of a democracy i mean
a democracy is based on the idea that
even if you lose
you should um you should uh lose
gracefully because you have a
chance to win the next time but what if
you don't what if you don't have a
chance to win the next time
then you begin to feel like this is not
a democracy and in fact it's not even
really a country
because ultimately one part of the
population is
ruling by force over the other i i think
the serious
implications of that we'll have to
consider very carefully if it comes to
that
and the courts are going to play a
central role here you know i was just
thinking back
when people when the same people who
told us that the 2016 election was
stolen
tell us that now elections can't be
stolen no one would stuff a ballot box
it couldn't happen i thought back to the
1948 senate race in texas
where lyndon johnson cheated he stole
the election from coke stevenson
this was a million ballot race johnson
won by 87 votes
they stuffed the ballot box specifically
box 13 from a very crooked county
they did discover this i mean it went up
to the supreme court
and robert carrow did a good job of
uncovering what really happened decades
and decades later johnson had already
left the white house
but it went up to the supreme court it
was so obvious johnson had stolen the
election
and the supreme court said sorry it's
not our jurisdiction we don't want to
deal with it's a state matter
they sent it back obviously johnson
takes the senate seat becomes vice
president becomes president doesn't
matter
that he stole it do you have faith do
you have trust in the courts that
they're going to
act responsibly here however the
evidence comes out you know
do you think they would have that
backbone if there were evidence of
systemic fraud or
are the courts just going to go weak the
courts can go either way
and i think in this case um a procedure
doesn't really do the trick because the
court could say well listen you know
this is up to the state legislatures to
fix
but here's the problem what if you're
talking swinging
states and you're talking about
democratic legislatures in some of those
states that are
organizing the rigging is the court
gonna say you know what it's a state
function if the states want to rig their
elections they totally can if they want
to assign three votes to one guy and one
vote to another guy
that's totally up to them i don't think
that's right i think that the courts
have got to realize that this is a
serious crisis of our democracy that
affects the whole country
every illegal vote cast cancels out a
legitimate vote cast
right so what they're doing is they're
disenfranchised us
our legal votes by introducing illegal
votes so i think this is not something
that can be
punted down the road i don't think it
can be ignored i don't think the supreme
court is going to be
careless enough and naive i mean this
would be like the dred scott decision
for them if they were to ultimately
wash their hands off the biggest issue
right now
essentially affecting american democracy
how do you think the right is doing
i'm not just talking about the legal uh
representatives of the campaigns i'm
talking about the people who are making
the case in the public
how do you think we're doing because
you've hit on something right here that
i think is
is really important the left always
talks about voter suppression
and every vote is very important and we
have to enfranchise people
and what you're saying is right but
every single time you have an
illegal vote you've just disenfranchised
a legal eligible voter are we making
that argument properly or are we falling
a little short of persuasion
we're we're suffering not from a lack of
persuasion
but from a lack of gigantic megaphones
to be able to get this message to 300
million americans
as you know even fox news has a reach of
5 million rush limbaugh has a big reach
talk radio has a big reach but the left
is able to penetrate into essentially
every american home so
they dominate the narrative not because
they're more persuasive
but because they have a wider reach so
we're feeling uh i think very keenly
the absence of having those big
megaphones and i think we've got to
realize we need to build them
but the simple reason that this doesn't
just just affect this
election but it affects every election
well right
because sometimes the left attacks us at
the daily wire because the daily wire
as a single outlet performs very well on
facebook which is just one social media
platform
one outlet one social media platform and
they say oh facebook's all in the tank
for conservatives
you say well look at all the other
platforms you know i got to fill in for
rush on friday it was
such a thrill that oh my gosh what a
huge audience
but even russia's audience is whatever
it is 25 million or something could even
be a little bit higher
you think oh my gosh that's unbelievable
what an achievement
and then compare that to nbc
cbs abc the washington post the new york
times the
every other media basically every other
media outlet
are left wing and so it doesn't matter
you you get the one
once in a lifetime rush limbaugh you get
you know a conservative outlet that does
well on one platform for a while
that gets drowned out in the broader
public by this
established empire of the leftist media
yeah i mean let's not even count abc nbc
and cbs just take you know
npr national public radio uh which is
subsidized by the government and has
become a fully occupied instrument of
the left
and and while rush is on for three hours
a day
npr is on all day um and so
what you have is uh that the left
controls the debate um
in a sense you could almost say that
this is their secret weapon
the media um and the media has become
brazenly dishonest i mean remember in
the old days
there was bias but there was at least
some obligation to impartiality to
fairness you could shame the media by
calling them to a higher standard look
at the way you've covered
reagan versus save carter or reagan
versus mondale and they'd go yeah
you know but now there's no point even
making these kinds of arguments because
they don't
have those higher standards of
objectivity they're not even pretending
to be
unbiased um and the
ness of this is i think become very
transparent
do you think that the the future of the
media will be
a return to say post world war ii
kind of liberal you know at least it's
liberal but they make a
a pretense of having these objective
standards or do you think it's going to
go back to say
the 18th or 19th century model where you
just have partisan press
and you got the tennessee democrat you
know and then you've got the other
the other paper and they they have their
candidates and they they own their
biases
is that going to be the future are they
going to keep up this pretense that
they're somehow
objective no i i think that depends on
us
if able to create alternative media that
have the same kind of reach
then we will have to stop listening to
them because i think we have to realize
not dealing with real reporters i mean
you're dealing with people who have
press badges
uh but they're essentially operatives
for the left yeah i mean think of a
reporter who goes to an
antifa rally and the antifa guys are
pulling some old guy out of a car
and beating them up and the antifa guy
turns to the reporters and goes
turn away your camera don't cover this
keep your camera focused only on the
cops
so when the cops come rushing in it now
appears like oh the cops are being so
heavy-handed
but you're not noting the antifa
bullying and the
antifa of thuggery that is leading to
this response so
and the media cooperates with this so
the media is part of antifa they are the
public relations arm
of antifa i think once we see this we've
got to realize these people aren't
reporters to
the fact that we take them seriously we
were like oh wolf blitzer said on cnn
this is part of the problem they are
living in our minds and we
reduce the power of the media in our
heads a great point because we are the
ones
talking about them we are the ones who
care what they say and in a way we sort
of have to because they have influence
but the more we talk about them the more
influence
they have it's such a good point i i
noticed one thing this scandalized even
me
and i have a pretty low uh respect for
big tech and the media very low
expectations president trump tweeted out
i won the election
which he's been saying since the
beginning joe biden says he won the
election trump says he won the election
and it said on the bottom not just that
the claim was disputed it said
official sources have called this
election
differently and i said well hold on a
second first of all president trump
he is an official you know i think the
president of the united states is is an
official but then i thought okay the
states have not certified the results
the electors have not voted those are
the officials who decide elections
so who who what referral or what
officials are they referring to
they were referring to the media and big
tech
and jack dorsey basically as the
officials
who rule us how did we get to that
situation
that's isn't that interesting they're
not talking about the supreme court that
would be an official source they're not
talking about the congress that would
official source uh they're not talking
about the electors or the electoral
college that would be an official source
oh it really shows you how we've come
unhinged from reality i mean i i posted
on facebook a couple of weeks ago i
quoted biden saying that antifa is
merely an idea
direct quote from biden just inaccurate
and facebook immediately goes
dinesh we're restricting you or
demonetizing you
we are we are putting a warning on this
that says lacking context so let's think
about this lacking
context what context i mean did biden
issue a lengthy study on antifa
no there was no context and what makes
this maddening is like with any other
company
you know let's say for example united
airlines cancels my reservation i can
call united and go listen you morons
you cancelled my reputation i've got i
paid for my ticket you know you can talk
to them and make them see reason
here there's no one to call yeah we just
got a bunch of weirdos and man buns
sitting around
jack dorsey's you know office look bad
this guy
you know so you're dealing with
essentially an absolute clown show
uh i don't even think i think even
george orwell would realize that not
only
is this tragic there's also an element
of sort of comic comedy to it
yes there is there is you you can laugh
or cry i suppose there is a kind of
dark humor in all of it uh we will find
out i mean
the the official sources i suppose will
decide this election at the court level
at the state legislature level
at the electoral level uh this uh
we can't say we didn't see this coming
those of us who saw trumpcard which i
recommend people go see
those of us who were listening to you
before the election could have seen this
coming
uh but maybe they weren't able to listen
to you maybe they weren't even able to
see
trumpcard because of the kind of
censorship that we're seeing from our
artificial official uh sources so in the
meantime
definitely encourage people to go check
out trumpcard and obviously follow
dinesh while you're still allowed to
before the man buns
kick you off of his page and dinesh
thank you so much as always for being
here
my pleasure
[Music]
you